ils ont raccroché le vélo la même année
à quelques jours d'intervalle tout un
symbole romain et brice ne prendront
plus le départ de courses
professionnelles
alors bien sûr c'est l'heure du bilan
avec des hauts et des bas pour les deux
frangins romain l'aîné tout d'abord
c'était le sprinteur vice champion du
monde juniors en 2006 à salzbourg
il se révèle au grand public l'année
d'après en 2007 il remporte
paris-bourges et le tour de grande
bretagne 2008
c'est le déclic il flirte avec la
victoire d'étape sur le tour de france à
trois reprises il est battu au soir de
la 3e étape par samuel dumoulin à nantes
mais le lot de consolation n'a pas de
prix romain feillu portes le lendemain
la tunique jaune tant convoité quarante
minutes inoubliables
lors du contre-la-montre autour de
cholet j'en ai rêvé
mardi mardi dernier j'ai fait j'ai fait
un rêve avons ce terreau de la bosse de
plumelec mais qu'il ya deux jours de
décalage mais c'est magnifique de le
prendre
2010 l'année la plus prolifique romain
feillu s'impose sur trois étapes du tour
méditerranéen et l'année suivante il
termine 6e des championnats du monde
avec l'équipe de france à copenhague
son frère cadet brice avait lancé sa
carrière de la plus belle des manières
passé pro en 2009 le grimpeur remporté
une magnifique victoire la même année à
moins de 24 ans le jeune coureur
d'agritubel part dans la bonne échappée
pour ensuite s'extirper du groupe de
tête à cinq kilomètres de l'arrivée
ils arrivent premiers au sommet
d'andorre arcalis lors de la 7e étape du
tour de france
une victoire qui devrait en appeler
d'autres moi je réalisais pas trop et en
roumain je pense qu'il a réalisé pour
moi là mais malheureusement ce ne sera
pas le cas bon grimpeur coéquipier loyal
brise terminera tout de même deux fois à
la 16e place du tour de france en 2014
et 2017 d'equipe en équipe de pépins
physiques en pépins physiques
les dernières années deviennent
difficiles pour les deux frérots
finalement fidèle à la région centre val
de loire qui les a vu grandir
romain choisi paris bourges le 10
octobre dernier pour tirer sa révérence
avant qu'il ne soit suivie quelques
jours plus tard par son petit frère
brice à l'issue de paris tours